ipw is  u.s travel's big show  and to have it in las vegas is  great for the city it's an honor for us  it's a show that travels throughout the  country international visitors are an  exceptionally important part of our  customer base they'll do about five  billion dollars in future travel and las  vegas will get probably at least 10 or  15 percent of it the great thing about  ipw this year is we were able to get  over 300 buyers from countries that were  blocked from coming here into the u.s  with something called the national  interest exemption the government  figured this is so important to the u.s  economy they brought these people in to  have it here is just fortuitous it was  supposed to be your last year and we  moved it to this year and i can't think  of a better location to showcase the  world is now open to bring business to  las vegas into the u.s